What panksepp observed,
I think this is a brilliant piece of
science,
is that first of all,
juvenile male routes in particular,
like too rough and tumble play,
they like to wrestle and they actually
pin each other just like little kids do,
or like adult wrestlers do.
They pinned their shoulders down and
that basically means you win.
And so okay,
so that's pretty cool.
But what's even cooler,
I think while there's three things,
one is the rats will work for an
opportunity to get into an arena where
they know that play might occur,
and so that's one of the scientific ways
of testing in animals motivation,
right?
So imagine you have a starving wrath and
it knows that it's got food down the end
of a corridor.
You can put a little spring on its tail
and measure how hard it pulls and that
gives you an indication of it's
motivational force.
Now imagine the starving rat that's
trying to get some food and you have a
little spring on his tail and you walked
in some cat odor,
so now that route is starving and wants
to get out of there.
He's going to try to pull even farther
towards the food,
so getting away plus getting forward are
separate motivational systems and if you
can add them together,
it's real potent and part of the reason
why in the future authoring exercise
that you guys are going to do as the
class progresses,
you're asked to outline the place you'd
like to end up,
which is your desired future,
and also the place that you could end up
if you let everything fall apart is so
that your anxiety chases you and your
approach systems pull you forward.
You're maximally motivated,
dead,
and it's important because otherwise you
can be afraid of pursuing the things
that you want to pursue.
Right?
And that's very common and so then the
fear inhibits you as the promise pulls
you forward,
but it makes you weak because you're
afraid.
You want to get your fear behind you,
pushing you,
and so what you want to be as afraid,
more afraid of not pursuing your goals
than you are of pursuing them.
It's very,
very helpful and lots of times in life,
and this is something really worth
knowing,
you know,
and this is one of the advantages to
being an autonomous adult,
is you don't get to pick the best thing.
You get to pick your poison,
you have two bad choices and you get to
pick which one you're willing to suffer
through and every choice has a bit of
that element in it.
And so if you know that,
it's really freeing because otherwise
you torture yourself by thinking,
well,
maybe there's a good solution to this.
You know,
compared to the bad solution.
It's like,
Nah,
Nah.
Sometimes there's just risky solution,
one and risky solution to and sometimes
both of them are really bad,
but you at least get to pick which one
you're willing to suffer through and
that's,
that actually makes quite a bit of
difference because you're also facing it
voluntarily that instead of chasing you,
and that is an entire different entirely
different psychophysiological response.
Challenge versus threat.
It's not the same.
Even if the magnitude of the problem is
the same.
And so putting yourself in a
challenging,
let's call it mind frame,
you can't just do that by magic.
Putting yourself in a challenging
mindframe is much,
much easier on you psychophysiological
because you don't produce,
you don't go into the generalized stress
response to the same degree and you're
activating your exploratory and seeking
systems which are dopaminergic mediated
and that involved positive emotion.
So if you can face something voluntarily
rather than having to chase you,
it's way better for you cycle
physiologically.
So that's partly why.
Well,
it's worthwhile to go find the dragon in
its layer instead of waiting for it to
come and eat.
So.
And especially when you also add the
idea that if you go find the dragon and
it's layer,
you might find it when it's a baby
instead of a full fledged bloody monster
that is definitely going to take you
down.
And so that's part of the reason why.
Well,
there's a whole bunch of things that,
that,
that emerge out of that observation.
Like don't avoid small problems that you
know,
are there,
face them because they'll grow into big
problems all by themselves.
And you can think about,
imagine the Tax Department sends you a
notification,
you owe them like $300.
Well it's,
you know,
that's annoying.
Maybe you don't even want to open the
letter or maybe if you do,
you just put it on the shelf,
but that damn thing doesn't just sit
there like a piece of paper on the
shelf,
right?
You ignore that for five or six years.
It's going to be come attached to all
sorts of horrible things and if you
ignore it long enough,
you get the idea,
it's going to turn into something that
is completely unlike the little piece of
paper that it's written on and,
and many,
many problems in life are like that.
You'll see they'll,
you'll see that they popped their ugly
little handout that you know and you
might want to turn away,
might want not want to think about it,
which is the easiest way of turning
away,
right?
You just don't attend to it.
It's not like you repress it or anything
like that.
You just fail to attend to it.
And that's a really as a longterm
strategy.
It's dismal.
It's also something that I think that's
more characteristic of people who are
high in neuroticism and high in
agreeableness.
Agreeable people don't like conflict and
people who are high in neuroticism,
we were highly negative.
Emotion are hit harder per unit of
uncertainty or threat,
and so you know,
and that's partly why in psychotherapy,
a lot of times the people you see need
assertiveness training,
so that would be the opposite of
agreeableness,
or they need to help get their anxiety
and emotional pain under control.
It's.
Those are not the only reasons.
There's antisocial behavior,
but you can't fix that in therapy.
In all likelihood.
There's alcoholism.
There's lots of lots of other reasons,
but those are two major reasons.